oh boy this is bad
i'm not a fan hey everyone i'm abby
sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by buildbar
and we'll be taking a look at beachbody
fitness coach autumn calabrese and her
nutrition program portion fix but first
let me tell you about my sponsor billbar
i'm gonna say it and i'm gonna say it
again these bars are really
really tasty like they don't taste like
protein bars they don't taste like chalk
masquerading as like a health food they
actually taste like chocolate but bonus
they have a lot of protein in them all
right today's flavor
pop the top i feel like it's a double
chocolate day because it's friday on the
day i'm filming this and on fridays we
eat chocolate let's
bust in
so we may still have
a lot of halloween candy downstairs in
the pantry but
i'm reaching for one of these bad boys
because these have 17 grams of protein
so good and i love them all on their own
but also they're really good on yogurt
or like i melt it a little bit in the
microwave for 10 seconds and then put
whipped cream on top or i cut it up and
put it into my warm oatmeal in the
morning
yes so good um and usually i have it
before bed for like a little bedtime
snack but if i was having it as a
post-workout snack i would pair it with
some oatmeal or some fruit like i just
said so if you want to try these guys
out yourself check out my link in the
description and use my promo code
abbiesharp15 to get 15 off of your order
all right before we get into it feel
free to pause the screen or look at the
description and check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating as always please
feel free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey and also
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
ring that bell so that you never miss
out on an episode and if you're not
already following me over on tick tock
or instagram hit me up at abby's kitchen
do not miss out okay guys so just a
heads up i'm not gonna be showing actual
footage from the paid program but i am
gonna be sharing my own experience
interacting with it as a kind of like
day pass member now if you are not
familiar with beachbody i have reviewed
them extensively in my shakeology video
right here and while the site does offer
two main nutrition weight loss programs
we're going to focus on portion fix
which is affiliated with fitness
influencer autumn calabresi in short the
program believes in manipulating portion
sizes using color coded containers to
avoid counting calories there are a few
main principles that the program
operates on principle one portion
control this is kind of pivotal to the
program that's all that fitting foods
into specific size containers now
obviously i do prefer this approach to
eliminating very specific foods or whole
food groups and i do appreciate that
some folks may need some guidance to
help encourage balance portion control
as diet culturally as that statement is
can help folks who have been heavily
restricting all of their lives see that
ultimately all foods can fit on their
plate but the whole container thing just
feels so archaic to me holy
like does anyone else feel like this is
something that they would buy from a
shady infomercial at 3am in the 90s you
know but wait if you order in the next
15 minutes we'll throw in a second set
for free just pay shipping and handling
but i'm not done yet i love the 90s but
i do not
love these so the general gist here is
that the bigger containers are for lower
calorie foods like fruits and vegetables
and the small ones are for things like
oils and fats more calorie dense foods
seems straightforward and maybe less
intimidating than calorie counting uh
until you try to use the containers in
real life now i guess if you're used to
eating like a bikini competitor like
autumn you know living the strict clean
meal prep life that
maybe this isn't so overwhelming i guess
it's like okay so you got your meal prep
sweet potatoes in one container and you
got your meal prep roasted broccoli in
the other container and you got your
meal prep salmon in the other container
great for those types of kind of like
simple assembly meals it makes sense but
how the
do you follow
like a recipe for
like a casserole or soup or some kind of
baked goods do you like deconstruct
every meal to make sure the components
perfectly fit in the appropriate
containers and you do that before or
after it's cooked i have questions like
i get it
having a system or some structure for
some folks makes it a lot easier for
them to meet their needs but this
specifically just doesn't really give
you a whole lot of wiggle room in real
life situations like going out to eat or
being in other public situations with
food and that to me is a big red flag
complying with the portion fix program
heavily depends on planning ahead and
knowing exactly what you're going to eat
that day so that you can allocate your
containers accordingly so not only are
you expected to have an awareness of
what foods correspond with like each
container category but you also need to
know the quantities of each food group
that went into your meal how many
containers in each category you have for
the day and then know how many you have
left so you can allocate them for your
next meal what and
this is apparently supposed to be easier
than calorie counting
girl who the
is we ain't doing that so you need
something about me so here's a little
example let's say you want to have
scrambled eggs with some toast greens
and a smoothie for breakfast before you
do that you have to pull out your food
list and determine how many containers
this accounts for based on your caloric
budget and then dock it from your daily
container tally but it gets even more
complicated when you don't use a full
container worth of food like let's just
say you only want to add like a few
tablespoons of yogurt to your smoothie
however there's no tablespoon option for
this on the food list which means you
have to measure this amount in your red
container and then take a mental note of
the empty space left over so you can put
it towards your next meal like what the
actual
honestly at this rate i think the main
reason i can see for weight loss on this
plan is that it may become
so cumbersome and annoying just to eat a
damn meal that you just decide to skip
it which obviously would not be healthy
or advised
moving on principle 2 is balanced macros
while a 40 30 30 split might work well
for some people on a population level
it's not some magic formula so research
shows that macronutrient ranges do not
make a significant impact on weight loss
as much as total caloric intake does
while other studies actually suggest
that 50 to 55 percent of calories from
carbs is really the sweet spot for a
decreased rate of mortality so if having
a higher percentage of calories from
carbs makes a diet more sustainable for
you then that's going to be a better
diet for you and this is why most diets
with specific rules don't make sense
because they just can't capture the
nuance and uniqueness of human nutrition
and speaking of uniqueness this is where
i want to discuss the calculation of
caloric needs so depending on your goals
you're assigned a calorie budget with
about 300 calories of wiggle room based
solely on your weight activity level and
your goal which again doesn't capture
the nuance of human nutrient needs more
importantly though why is there a
caloric budget on a plan that insists
that it's not a diet sorry even more
specifically why is 1200 calories even
an option because while technically of
course there are probably people out
there who need only 1200 calories it's
more realistically the needs of a
toddler so i do think it's risky and
irresponsible to be prescribing numbers
as low as that without supervision it is
really hard to meet your micro and
macronutrient needs on a diet as
restrictive as that so again that's a
problem despite the fact that we've been
sold that we don't need to eliminate
anything and that this is not a real
diet portion fix sneaks in some overt
restriction in their third principle
eliminate highly processed foods now
that i guess you're officially hooked in
with the pitch we throw in all the
wellness culture buzzwords so processed
foods sugar natural chemicals yikes lots
to unpack here but let's start with
processed foods now processed foods
exist on a spectrum and can absolutely
be part of a healthy varied diet take
things like almond milk hummus frozen
vegetables or greek yogurt these healthy
food items are nutrient dense and are
often included in autumn's recipes but
do they naturally exist in nature no no
they don't they require some level of
processing and are therefore considered
a processed food in fact even the
healthy apple pie substitute autumn
presents contains processed ingredients
like graham crackers and coconut oil not
to mention shakeology is actually an
ultra processed protein product that is
pushed as a regular fixture of the
program along with a number of other
ultra processed foods on the food list
so yeah buzzy scapegoat words like
processed just can't capture the nuance
of nutrition quality and variety now on
the flip side we have qualifying terms
like all natural or organic which often
gives foods an automatic health halo
also last to say about this for one all
natural is actually not a regulated term
so it actually doesn't necessarily mean
much cheetos can be called natural fyi
even though i have never seen a cheeto
in the wild
but likewise whole foods organic cookies
are still freaking cookies and they too
are made in a manufacturing plant
alongside non-organic cookies now a
common example of what we call the
natural fallacy and wellness culture
that we see play out in this plan is the
demonizing of white sugar in favor of
honey or maple syrup now we see this
favoritism constantly in the name of
health and naturalness despite the fact
that both types of sugar have virtually
the same sucrose chemical composition
and are recognized similarly in the body
also for the record all foods are made
up of chemicals every single one so the
common suggestion to avoid it if you
can't pronounce it is rooted in elitism
and also just totally misinformed so
words like
cyanocobalamin or
coal
calciferol i mean they're big and scary
and i can barely say them but they're
actually just the chemical names of b12
and vitamin d respectively which are
added to a lot of healthy foods to make
them more nutrient dense also if we put
those last two points together it's also
worth mentioning that there's no
difference between natural and synthetic
versions of a chemical if the chemical
structure is the same it doesn't matter
if the chemical was extracted from a
plant or synthesized in a lab also oh my
god i'm still going here but even with
foods that are highly processed the dose
makes the poison so eating a hot dog at
the 4th of july barbecue with your
coleslaw and your fruit salad not a big
deal eating only hot dogs for your
entire adult life maybe not ideal so if
you are not considering the dose while
making claims that something is bad for
you or toxic you are contributing
fear-mongering misinformation to an
already bs saturated world again i'm not
here for it now i want to close off my
review of this allegedly simple program
by sharing these insights on food
substitutions and treats as autumn says
you can have a treat and that means
dessert or alcohol up to three times a
week but when you do this you do have to
substitute it in and this goes for any
calorie bracket that you're in you can
have wine but no more than three five
ounce glasses a week you can have
dessert portion fix approved up to three
times a week but it's no more than three
swaps total a week for alcohol and
dessert combined uh for a simple program
that is flexible and not a diet i'm
hearing a ton of complicated rules the
program allows you to eat the foods you
enjoy but in the right portion size and
you can only do so up to three times a
week plus it needs to be substituted in
one of your container counts and it has
to be a fixate approved recipe and you
can never have dessert and booze at the
same time
uh the more rules i hear the more i want
to break them anyone else feel me on
that
so there is definitely merit to meal
planning i think it can help us make
more mindful and budget-friendly
decisions but it is totally unrealistic
and unsustainable to plan every detail
of your diet seven days out of the week
just so that you can allow yourself a
treat life is unpredictable and it's
mentally unhealthy to need to obsess
over every single bite to this degree
like it feels like this program sets you
up with the tools to micromanage your
eating to the point where you can't even
have a treat without doing a full
math calculation in your head oh
sounds totally exhausting and
unrealistic it's also worth mentioning
that a margarita or a slice of cake is
not even calorically equivalent to a
slice of toast anyway so i'm not even
sure what kind of skills or nutrition
knowledge they're trying to impart with
that also a quick note on autumn's
approach and online presence in general
now it took some time to scroll through
autumn's instagram to just get a better
sense of her personal brand as it
relates to portion fix and beachbody on
demand now first of all in case you're
wondering the beachbody workouts are
encouraged but not absolutely mandatory
as a part of the portion fix program
same with shakeology there's a lot of
cross-promotion of sub-brands but i
think that keeping them separate also
gives the illusion that there's kind of
something for everyone here having
autumn strategically promote these
sister brands while kind of keeping them
separate also helps to drive this
illusion home now specific to the
program there are a lot of
sensationalized messages going on that i
just do not love so for one she
positions the program as the anecdote
for bloat sugar addiction low energy etc
she also uses a tag like portion fix to
fix your life which seems like a bit of
a lofty claim and when i read her
position related to code 19 risks and
obesity where she suggested that we are
in control of this i realized that she's
just a little out of touch
yes there's some element of control in
our behaviors and those behaviors may or
may not affect our risk of obesity but
to reduce obesity to a choice we make to
reduce the spread of a virus is elitist
reductionist and stigmatizing as
i really don't have all the time in the
world to go into all the details on the
social determinants of health but yeah
unfortunately processed crap as she
calls it is a lot more accessible than
veggies fruit lean protein and healthy
carbs to a lot of folks in a lot of
communities especially to those living
in food deserts or in poverty and while
doing a workout on beachbody on demand
may be cheaper than hiring a personal
trainer and paying the 119 for the
portion fixed containers may be cheaper
than hiring a dietitian it's still
likely isn't realistic to the single
parent who's working three jobs on the
front lines just trying to make ends
meet as a health care provider i know
it's really hard to support people who
have limited resources like money and
time so i do assume that her heart is in
the right place but please do not shame
people in larger bodies for
not taking control of this it will never
be as simple as choosing broccoli over
candy when our body size or health are
involved so in conclusion i don't think
that this is a particularly dangerous
program in the grand scheme of
influencer-led weight loss programs i
mean there are far more restrictive
programs out there that you know are
just riddled with misinformation and
disordered eating easter eggs planted
throughout the reading materials but i
need you all to know that this is
absolutely a diet and really no
different than any other diet you've
ever tried it doesn't matter if you're
counting calories points like i
discussed in my weight watch video right
here or
colored containers it all involves the
same obsessive and exhaustive mental
gymnastics portion fix is the same diet
dressed up in a different color or
multiple colors in this case so not
surprisingly it is a hard pass for me
and on that note that is all that i have
for you guys today if you like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on who or what
you'd like to see in your view next
subscribe to the channel and a big thank
you to buildbar for sponsoring and i
will see you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]